a digital rug and this frog is the
smallest vertebrae on the planet at
about seven point seven millimeters
Vsauce Kevin here this is Monica the
orchim 3d reconstruction system can
automatically capture real-world objects
and reproduce them as 3d images an
object is placed inside the
reconstruction sphere and then captured
with an omnidirectional scanning process
that allows light patches to illuminate
all angles of the object we creating its
exterior instantly and perfect oh my god
that doubles word of Awesomeness chaotic
moon labs created a motorized skateboard
controlled by you it uses a Kinect and a
tablet that includes a video and speech
recognition so to move forward you move
your hand forward to slow down bring
your hand back the Kinect can also help
you pick out your outfit face kick
swivel virtual dressing-room removes the
hassle of trying on clothes and
ultimately could be used to aid online
shoppers a Bulgarian artist spent 16
years creating this matchstick monastery
it consists of six million matchsticks
and he finally completed this massive
project honoring the largest and most
famous Eastern Orthodox monastery in
Bulgaria
[Music]
oh if you want to study ants you might
have to paint them scientists and code
unique identifications onto each and a
colony in order to effectively study and
differentiate they use different
patterns of colored dots and this video
teaches you exactly how they do it find
the link below to chill your warm soda
freakishly fast
LG's blast chilling fridge siphons cold
air from the freezer taking a
room-temperature pop to 42 degrees
Fahrenheit in about five minutes water
typically spells doom for electronics
unless it's coated with Liquipel a new
thin clear coating that causes water to
beat right off your smartphone
protecting it inside and out from a
potential watery grave the rainbow
eucalyptus is the only eucalyptus found
naturally in the northern hemisphere and
has patches of outer bark that shed at
different times
revealing bright green inner bark and
then matures and darkens to the blue
orange purple and maroon tones finally a
new music video from 8bit weapon called
bits with white
[Music]
I'm gonna leave you with unicorn poop
cookies
[Music]
there are four clues in the description
of this video the first person to get
all four correct will be our genius of
the week so good luck and as always
thanks for watching